for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so when it comes to electron
configurations the question is how are
the atomic orbitals filled with
electrons to answer that we have to
consider the Alpha Bell principle an Alf
bowel means to build up in German or
something like that at least anyway the
Aufbau principle guidelines what we have
to keep in mind the first guideline is
that low-energy orbitals are filled
before high energy orbitals so we have
to know that ok which means specifically
we also have to know the actual order of
the energies of the different atomic
orbitals so how do you remember that
well that's where this little thing here
comes in mind comes into play this
little situation right here this thing
is is gold right here ok basically if
you write this out 1s 2s 2p 3s 3p 3d so
on and so forth just like this all the
way up to 7p what you'll get is a really
really useful tool to help you remember
the energy to the atomic orbitals so
really what we're going to do is we're
going to start at the top right here and
draw a line from the top right to the to
the bottom left and as we do that
through this little this little
representation here we're going to
basically know the order in which the
atomic orbitals are filled so first
we're going to go through the 1s orbital
after that got 2s orbital then the 2p
then the 3s then the 3p then the 4s then
the 3d followed by the 4p and then 5s
then we've got 4 D 5 p-6 s and then 4 f
5 D 6 p-7 s and then 5f 67p that should
be other ones that we are exposed to in
any general chemistry course so that's
really really helpful and really really
useful and I would encourage you to keep
that around whenever you're working on
studying through electron configurations
and especially when you're doing
practice problems second guideline is
that we have to keep in mind at the
orbitals max occupancy a
is two electrons and each of them have
opposing spins we've come across this
concept before that was specifically the
Pauli exclusion principle okay so when
we go through and fill orbitals we have
to make sure that if we put one with a
positive one half spin then the other
one has to have a minus one half spin
now this last one here if two or more
orbitals with the same energy are
available to be filled with electrons
one electron will go into each orbital
until all the orbitals are half full and
all of them must have the same spin this
has to occur before you double up on any
electrons and orbitals this rule is
called hund's rule okay you might be
thinking why why what's going on with
hund's rule why is that a thing okay why
do we care why does it happen like that
let's go through and explain that so if
we think about hund's rule imagine three
electrons we have three electrons left
to fill a set of P orbitals or P
orbitals or the pizza sub shell has
three orbitals so here we have the
negative 10 and Plus Ones M sub L values
that represent the three different
orbitals so if we have three electrons
left what that means that when we're
going through and filling these orbitals
we have to specifically fill them all
halfway before we double up on any so
we're going to put one here and then one
here and then one here so they're all
half filled and they all have the same
spin they're all spinning upwards okay
we cannot fill it in like this one up
one down and one up because they're not
all half-filled we don't put two in the
same orbital before we have all of them
half filled okay we also can't do this
we can't put them like one up and then
one down and then another down or
something like that they all have to
have the same spin so these we cannot
have this or that question is why right
well the reason is because electrons
repel they repel so they want to be
farther apart
if that's possible okay because if
they're farther apart they're going to
be lower in energy and more stable so in
this first situation up here and this
one we've got these two right next to
each other in the same orbital when they
could be separate one of them could be
in this orbital out here but it's not so
that's not right okay this is not as
stable as it could be also electrons
stay further apart when they have the
same spin right and that's actually why
the second situation is not going to
happen if this one has an up spin that's
a really horrible arrow if this one has
an of spin and these two have down spins
then they're going to be not they're not
going to be as far apart as they could
be if they all have the same spin right
if they have if they have opposite spin
there's they're more likely to be
slightly closer together which is not a
stable and not as lower in energy okay
so this is a situation we want okay if
we had four electrons after we fill in
these three then we can go back and add
the fourth and so and maybe if we had a
fifth and six we would do that but
that's not what happened here okay so
let's start with the electron
configurations of the first two rows of
the bureau our table which is we're
going to talk about in the next video
and then we'll move on to more hope that
video is helpful thanks for watching if
you found that video helpful don't
forget to Like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying